my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
University comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy so in this video I
want to talk about the hormonal control
of acetyl co a carboxylase of course
we've already mentioned the regulation
in the previous video we're going to
talk specifically about how hormones
play a role in this regulation here so
let's consider two different scenarios
so the first scenario is you are you a
healthy normal individual wake up after
an excellent 10 hour sleep and you're
going to have a workout before you eat
an amazing breakfast that a world-class
chef is preparing for you sounds like a
pretty awesome morning in my opinion
anyway so you just will go from a 10
hour sleep so that means that you are in
the fasted State and if you are in the
fasted state what's going to be true is
that you're going to have fairly low
blood glucose levels that are being
maintained your removal cells are going
to be maintained at a normal but fairly
low relatively low level and you're also
going to have low glycogen stores
because they'll be depleted from
anything that you might have used in
entering your fast now in the fasted
state what is the dominated hormone the
dominant hormone is glucagon in the
fasted State so Google on is the
dominant hormone in the fastest day and
that's actually what is maintaining your
blood glucose levels so when this is the
case you have low blood glucose levels
low glycogen stores
what will your body use for energy
during your workout well it's going to
be using fatty acids so and how it's
going to be using them specifically is
that beta oxidation will be occurring to
break down those fatty acids for energy
so if this is the case if we're using in
fact just as a general note that fatty
acids are sort of a long tour long-term
energy source so especially if you have
a workout that's going to like involve
some aerobic exercise your fatty acids
are going to be used so beta
we'll be happening so if that's the case
do we want fatty acid synthesis to be
active well if beta oxidation is
occurring then no right we don't want to
have both fatty acid synthesis in beta
oxidation occurring at the same time
that wouldn't make any sense now if this
is the case for the fastest date with
guns the dominant hormone we're using
fatty acids for energy via beta
oxidation we don't want fatty acid
synthesis active what will go on what
you expect we're going to be doing to
pseudocode carboxylase well if i Sirocco
a carboxyl ices are committed enzyme to
fatty acid synthesis and we're don't
want fatty acid this is to be occurring
with goo-goo guns around glucagon will
inhibit it it'll inhibit acetyl co a
carboxylase
what does glucagon actually do well it
drives fatty acids to be used as fuel in
the fascist state they're a long term
energy source and when you're fasting
that's when your body's primary source
of energies is is fatty acids
now epinephrine not exactly the same
thing although it kind of works along
with global gone epinephrine is a is
like the the hormone that you might have
heard is associated with the
fight-or-flight response and essentially
what that's referring to is that it's
the fire in the fight-or-flight response
you need an immediate you need an energy
immediately so epinephrine is used to
satisfy immediate energy needs and what
it does is it it amplifies that bhuvan's
effect on map mobilizing fatty acid so
it further perpetuates what Google yuan
is already doing so they kind of work
together in that sense so the as a sort
of all-inclusive summary of what we've
done an epinephrine are doing together
is glucagon and epinephrine let's erase
all this uncover the hidden message
glucagon and epinephrine are both
catabolic hormones right they're
breaking down these fatty acids or
they're involved in breaking down these
fatty acids that work together in the
fasted state to mobilize fatty acids to
be used for energy okay so we just
mentioned that as such they favour
acetyl co a carboxylase to be in the
inactive state
the phosphoryl is a inhibiting fatty
acid synthesis from occurring so what
that looks like up here is that if they
want um the carboxyl is to be inactive
they don't want fatty acid synthesis to
occur what are they going to do are they
going to increase protein phosphatase to
aise activity or am P activated protein
kinase activity well which one
inactivates the carboxylase the A&P
activated protein kinase so the activity
of that enzyme will be increased by
clicking on an epinephrine okay cool
second scenario the second scenario
right after your workout you grow up on
your post-workout feast like a ferocious
beast and you've consumed plenty of
macro nutrients including carbs protein
your fat so in this case you're in the
fed state right so if you just ate your
blood glucose levels are going to be
high right and in this case in the
scenario the dominant hormone is insulin
insulin is the dominant hormone in this
case so what insulin is going to do is
it's going to lower blood glucose levels
and increase energy storage so I so do
we want fatty acid synthesis to be
active if we just ate if insulin is the
dominant hormone well yeah right we want
to store all the energy that we just ate
right so so we're going to store the fat
any fat fatty acids as triglycerides so
what will insulin do it at zero co a
carboxylase well we just said that if
it's going to activate fatty acid
synthesis we want this carboxylase to be
active so it's going to activate it so
what is insulin do insulin drives the
storage of energy including the storage
of fatty acids as triglycerides so
that's just reiterating what I just said
so now what's the little summary of
what's going on with insulin uncover the
hidden message so insulin unlike will
queue on an epinephrine is an anabolic
hormone and it dominates in the fed
state to store consumed energy right
part of the reason
lowers blood glucose levels right
increases the uptake of glucose and all
of that so as such it favors acetyl co a
carboxyl is to be in the active or non
phosphorylated State activating fatty
acid synthesis so if we look up here
fatty acid synthesis right is done by
this or committed to buy this
carboxylate enzyme is active one so we
want this active one to be around and
which which of these enzymes favors this
is protein phosphatase two eight just
gets rid of this phosphate to give us
this this active form enzyme and that's
what we want that's what insulin well at
least that's what insulin wants right so
the activity of this protein phosphatase
2a is increased by insulin so as to
activate the carboxylase allowing fatty
acid synthesis to occur so the overall
summary is simply that moving on an
epinephrine they inhibit acetyl co a
carboxylase and fatty acid synthesis
while insulin activates a co co a
carwash Laysan fatty acid synthesis hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching